tú
[Música]
hola mi nombre es susana reche a ustedes
recuerdan cuáles eran sus ilusiones
cuando tenían 16 años
y como esté visualizado en 15 años
después pues cuando yo tenía 16 años una
de mis más grandes alegrías era estar en
el primer año de universidad en la
universidad de san carlos de guatemala
estudiando ingeniería química cuando
tenía 27 terminé mi doctorado en la
universidad de castilla-la mancha en el
tema de nanotecnología en españa a
partir de eso puede compartir en
diferentes conferencias nacionales e
internacionales he sido invitado a más
de 9 países con todos los gastos pagados
sin embargo cuando tenía 16 años no me
imaginaba 15 años después aquí
presentándome en frente de ustedes como
una científica frustrada y más adelante
les explicaré a qué me refiero con
frustrada
en esta fotografía pueden verme en el
milagro
era un milagro si no te robaba y yo
crecí en esta zona y cerca de ciudad
quetzal y estoy muy orgullosa de haber
crecido en estas zonas rojas de
guatemala y de haber nacido en una
familia con limitaciones económicas
porque me enseñaron a luchar para salir
adelante así que hoy voy a hablarles de
cómo aprendí a motivar a niños ya
jóvenes mujeres a estudiar carreras stem
porque si yo pude lograrlo cualquiera
puede hacerlo y para los que no estén
relacionados con el término están se
refiere a ciencia tecnología ingeniería
artes y matemáticas por sus siglas en
inglés y el fomento de las carreras de
stem o carreras científicas es muy
importante a nivel global cuántos de
ustedes consideran que los científicos
son importantes que levanten la mano
bueno pues los científicos son muy
importantes porque producen nuevos
conocimientos estudian mecanismos
fenómenos cambios además lideran
soluciones avances tecnológicos y pueden
educar guiar y sensibilizar así que
incluso las naciones unidas destaca la
importancia de la inversión en
investigación e innovación como parte de
un proceso de crecimiento y desarrollo
económico sin embargo hay países en los
que no se invierte suficiente en estos
temas como lo es guatemala y es que en
guatemala el 0.0 29% del producto
interno bruto es invertido en este tema
a qué se refiere este valor es una
comparación 25 veces menos que el
promedio en américa latina y el caribe y
casi 200 veces menos que países como
israel o república de korea así que no
se invierte suficiente y tampoco somos
suficientes investigadores de 16
millones
habitantes sólo 400 personas hacen
investigación a tiempo completo así que
para mí es muy importante fomentar las
carreras científicas para que existan
más en el mundo en especial en nuestro
país y en especial con un enfoque en
género y es que hay muchos estudios que
muestran que la brecha de género en las
carreras científicas empiezan desde muy
pequeños desde el jardín infantil para
ser exactos de que es lo que normalmente
o tradicionalmente se le regala a un
niño
y quiero escuchar
y a una niña
claro y es que la organización es de
cooperación para el desarrollo económico
también destaca que ellos tienen como
países miembros 34 países y observaron
que las niñas a partir de los 15 años ya
saben que no van a ser ingenieras ellas
ya están seguras de que no van a
estudiar ingeniería a pesar de que no
hay una diferencia stem entre las
capacidades de un niño o una niña hacen
una visualización de que el problema es
por parte de la sociedad quiénes
inculcamos esa tradición de que para un
niño está bien las herramientas los
carros las naves espaciales los aviones
mientras que para una niñas también los
trastecitos de cocina las muñecas los
espejos y así empezamos a generar esa
brecha que poco a poco va generando una
percepción en las niñas de que nosotros
suficientemente buenas en estas áreas
también hay otros estudios que
demuestran que desde 3º primaria las
niñas se sienten inferiores que los
niños en matemáticas aunque los estudios
y las evaluaciones
muestran todo lo contrario así que esto
sucede desde muy cortas edades y cuando
yo reflexiono acerca de mi niñez y de
cómo era en primaria es que a mí tampoco
me gustaban las matemáticas y no era muy
buena
cuántas de las mujeres que están aquí en
este salón se sentían mal es para
matemáticas en primaria que levanten la
mano
hay un buen grupo
a mí me pasa da igual y fue hasta en
básicos que tuve una profesora que me
inspiró y que me retuvieron la profesora
demasiado exigente pero también me
motivó a demostrarme a mí misma que si
se podía y así fue como vivo empezaron a
gustar las matemáticas y poco a poco me
fue enfocando en las carreras
científicas y siempre tuvo el apoyo de
mis tropas que me enseñaron este
servicio a la comunidad y también el
luchar por salir adelante y que las los
problemas económicos no fueran una
limitación y así fue como obtuve mi
primer beca cuando tan sólo tenía 14
años de edad cuando tenía 14 puede
estudiar en el colegio bachillerato con
orientación en computación científica
así que eso me dio todas las bases para
poder estudiar ingeniería en la
universidad pública
al finalizar la ingeniería tuve la
oportunidad con una beca de fundación
carolina de estudiar una maestría y un
doctorado en españa y yo venía durante
todos esos cuatro años y medio y me
ponía la bata y los lentes
al laboratorio desde las 9 de la mañana
salida a 781 de la noche corriendo para
poder llegar a tiempo a la cena de la
residencia ya que el último horario era
nueve y media y si no no sé nada y fue
una experiencia muy bonita porque puedes
compartir en el laboratorio también con
muchas mujeres científicas muy
inspiradoras al mismo tiempo puede
conocer diferentes culturas puede
conocer muchos países de europa y pude
aprender de química orgánica y de
nanotecnología y quiénes de ustedes han
visto los avengers
un buen grupo también se recuerdan con
qué tipo de tecnología hacia su traje
aeromar
bueno pues les tengo una noticia la
nanotecnología no solo se utiliza para
realizar trajes de superhéroes como iron
man o black panther también funciona en
la vida real para poder solucionar
problemas que están planteados en los
objetivos de desarrollo sostenible y es
aquí donde les quiero enseñar estos
objetivos para los que no los conocen
son objetivos globales que se han
planteado desde 2015 hasta 2030 para
poder cumplir con tres misiones la
primera es poder terminar con la pobreza
la segunda es proteger al planeta y la
tercera es mejorar las condiciones de
vida de las futuras generaciones y
entonces se preguntarán cómo es que la
nanotecnología puede aplicar con esto
puedo apoyar con esto así que cuando
hablamos de nanotecnología hablamos de
algo muy pequeño de estudios de
materiales a 1 por 10 al menos 9 metros
para que tengan una idea es como la
relación entre el planeta tierra y una
manzana esa es la relación entre una
manzana y un material nano estructurado
entonces a ese tamaño tan pequeñito
ocurren varios efectos desde los efectos
cuánticos y también los efectos de
superficie que permiten que los
materiales se comporten diferentes y que
tengan aplicaciones tanto en energía
construcción informática salud ambiente
entre otras entonces por ejemplo se
pueden diseñar nuevos paneles solares y
baterías con mejores eficiencias que
puedan llegar a ese billón de personas
de todo el mundo que aún no tiene acceso
a energía eléctrica incluyendo 1.5
millones de guatemaltecos y así poder
cumplir con el objetivo número 7 que es
energía limpia y asequible
así que luego de estar en españa jugando
una beca fulbright para poder ir a eeuu
a una de las mejores universidades del
mundo eyeos y berlín hacer investigación
más aplicada ya no solo eran el
laboratorio sino ahora tenía que hacer
investigación en energía renovable
siempre sola pero en comunidades
aisladas de latinoamérica nuestro caso
de estudio fue guata con dos chiles pero
había muchas similaridades con lo que se
vive aquí en el país y en este momento
en mi vida muchas personas pensaron que
se me había ido la cabeza pensaron que
de tanto estudiar se me había quemado
algo ahí porque conocí a un perfecto
desconocido me enamoré perdidamente y al
mes nos casamos sin preguntarle a nadie
así que ni siquiera mi mamá así que
bueno yo estaba muy feliz esta me sentía
completa messen tía con estas emociones
de regresar a mi país y poder colaborar
porque siempre era mi meta poder
trabajar en guatemala así que regresó en
y empiezo a vivir una experiencia
complicada en primer lugar no conseguía
trabajo como investigador
cuando al fin conseguir trabajo como
investigadora tenía solo medio tiempo mi
solo no era muy bueno bueno no importaba
lo más importante es que me tuvo que
quitar la bata y me tuve que quitar los
lentes de laboratorio porque no teníamos
equipo suficiente o reactivos o recursos
así que tuve que empezar a escribir
propuestas de investigación y así me
tuve que vincular con investigadores
nacionales que es un grupo pequeño pero
con muchas ganas de hacer grandes
cambios por el país también con
investigadores internacionales y así fue
como pude armar los consorcios que me
permitieron concursar en varias para
varios sectores que ofrecen aquella
ayuda económica como son la secretaría
nacional de ciencia y tecnología la
academia de ciencias para países en vías
de desarrollo la unión europea y también
el consejo superior de investigaciones
científicas en españa- así que estaba
muy contenta tú ves estos cinco
proyectos
estuve desarrollando toda esta
colaboración
pero conforme fueron pasando los años me
fui dando cuenta que mis índices como
investigadora fueron decreciente
bastante y entonces me empieza a sentir
bastante frustrada porque para los que
no están relacionados y esto es algo así
como los exámenes del colegio y el
cuadro de honor entonces desde que yo
descubrí que para estar en el cuadro de
honor nos tiene que ser un genio sino
que se tiene que esforzar uno mucho y
hacer sacrificios para lograrlo a mí
siempre me había gustado estar en los
primeros lugares pero ahora como
investigadora en un país en vías de
desarrollo no podía seguir avanzando al
mismo ritmo que antes ya no podía
publicar la misma cantidad de
publicaciones de la misma calidad de
revistas científicas entonces fue un
proceso bastante complicado en la semana
pasada tuve el gusto de estar con
investigadores de países en vías de
desarrollo de áfrica del sureste de asia
y américa latina y nepal y todos
compartíamos las mismas limitaciones la
falta de equipos de alta tecnología de
muchas veces la burocracia la
dependencia política
así que para mí fue un poco frustrante
pero también en 2018 ocurrió algo muy
especial y es que pude compartir después
de pasar esta etapa puede compartir con
más de 3500 niñas
acerca de lo que es estudiar carreras
científicas durante todo el año estuve
en diferentes eventos que me permitieron
interactuar con ellas y conocer sus
pensamientos y es que era curioso porque
de cada 30 niñas al menos 3 me decían
que ellas si querían seguir una carrera
científica pero que sus padres se los
habían prohibido porque esas carreras
eran de hombres en 2018 seguía
sucediendo eso y muchas veces en la
ciudad
luego me doy cuenta que muchas niñas
también me decían que no se sentían muy
buenas para estas carreras y es ahí
donde yo abra los ojos porque para mí
siempre había sido normal que hubieran
más hombres que mujeres en ingeniería y
nunca lo vi cómo que el problema fuera
más grande que una simple falta de
interés la raíz del problema era mucho
más profunda y así es cuándo empieza a
leer estudios de género y estudios de
ciencia y me dio cuenta que eso no sólo
sucede aquí sino también sucede en otros
países por ejemplo eeuu y la national
science fundation hace un estudio en el
que declara que aunque el rendimiento
universitario de hombres y mujeres sea
muy similar los títulos universitarios
en carreras de computación ingeniería y
matemáticas para mujeres son mucho menor
estas son ustedes mucho menor la
cantidad de mujeres que entran a estas
carreras así que es cuando yo empieza a
evaluar todos estos estudios y es cuando
empiezo a organizar un programa
específico para niñas y mujeres en
comunidades rurales
y así empiezo a trabajar con este
desconocido del que les abre previamente
donde ahora tengo tres años y medio de
casados él tiene una empresa que fundó
con el just y berlín que se trata de
llevar energía renovable a comunidades
aisladas en áfrica y américa latina así
que ahora no sólo llevamos esos
dispositivos hay otros paneles solares y
con ese software de comunicación sino
también generamos estos programas que
puedan mejorar las capacidades de las
personas así que esta es una fotografía
del centro que tenemos en santa rosa y
esta es otra fotografía de las niñas
cuando ya están aprendiendo ahí en su
curso de alfabetización digital también
hacemos experimentos de ciencia entre
otras actividades
y es que hoy bueno en un par de meses
cuando mi hija nazca yo quiero que ella
decida su propio camino pero que se
sienta con el coraje y con la
inspiración de poder seguir sus sueños y
que las brechas de género no sea algo
que limiten su libertad intelectual o
personal así que yo quiero dejarlos con
tres peticiones y cuántos de ustedes
ahora reflexionando se dan cuenta que
han aportado a aumentar esa brecha de
género tal vez sin darse cuenta en la
ciencia
son pocos
bueno entonces les pido la primera es
incrementar el equipo porque el mundo
necesita niñas y niños que se conviertan
en científicos sin importar dónde
nacieron y sin importar su género porque
necesitamos enfocarnos en poder
compartir con ellos la juventud a nivel
mundial vive el 85% de la población en
países en vías de desarrollo y guatemala
el más del 70% de su población es menor
de 30 años de edad y esta población
joven es la que mejor necesita
orientación y educación de calidad y un
aprendizaje de vida así que
incrementemos este equipo el segundo
punto en el que les quiero pedir apoyo
es compartir y compartir sus
conocimientos historias sueños
frustraciones y éxitos porque cuantos de
aquí en algún momento de su vida también
se han sentido frustrados académicamente
y profesionalmente
y cuántas de aquí en algún momento se
han sentido totalmente exitosos
y es que la vida es así está llena de
frustraciones y de satisfacciones pero
tenemos que aprender a que no importa la
etapa que estemos viviendo podemos
compartir esto porque puede apoyar a
otros así que mi tercera petición es
transmitir e inspirar para que otros que
no han tenido las mismas oportunidades
lo puedan lograr muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]